looks like it's time to get started I'm
very happy to introduce Sunday keeper
that's gonna talk about commentarial
properties of the bicycle a layman under
thank you very much yeah as Nia said I'm
going to present you some combinatorial
results on the Weisse Philemon algorithm
and also the equivalent formulations and
logics the results three ways to measure
the power and complexity of the
algorithm so they might eventually be
helpful in order to approach graph
isomorphism yeah as a reminder the
problem to decide whether to given
graphs are isomorphic or not is in the
complexity class NP but its precise
complexity remains open in particular
it's not known whether it's in the class
P in his breakthrough as well from last
year Bob I got to show after decades of
research that it can actually be solved
in quasi-polynomial time and in his
proof he uses he heavily relies on a
poly logarithmic dimensional variant of
the algorithm of the advice Philemon
algorithm so yeah it's not only in his
proof but basically in in all approaches
theoretical and practical approaches to
chain graph isomorphism a very
indispensable subroutine how does the
algorithm work
so the algorithm iteratively refines a
coloring of the vertices of the given
graph of the given graph more precisely
the K dimensional variant computes the
coloring of the K topples of the
vertices in iterations so the one
dimensional algorithm which is also
called color refinement computes the
coloring of the of the vertices
themselves and how does it do it in the
refinement step which is the step that
is applied repeatedly to vertices that
had the same color before now
different colors if there is a color so
that they have a different number of
neighbors in this color and this is
applied until the induced partition
doesn't change any more than we call the
coloring stable and this is actually
what the algorithm returns and why is it
why it's useful for graph isomorphism is
because if you have two graphs and they
result in non isomorphic stable
colorings with respect to any dimension
of the vise philemon algorithm then
these graphs are non isomorphic so
therefore they can can be used in
applications to decide graph isomorphism
but yeah by the Cyclorama my
construction no dimension of the
algorithm actually suffice is to decide
graph isomorphism by itself so it can
only be used as a tool but not as the
only tool and yeah the the inverse is
not true so there are graphs which are
non isomorphic but have non isomorphic
stable colorings so you would need
something more you can only use it as a
subroutine and that's what it how it's
used so if you want to use it as a
subroutine sooner or later you basically
get to two main questions which I'm
going to treat here so the first one is
what is the power of the algorithm so
for which graphs does it actually
suffice to only use the algorithm to
apply graph isomorphism so for which
graphs can you apply the algorithm and
decide based only based on the stable
colorings whether they are isomorphic or
not and by the famous correspondence two
logics this actually is equivalent to
define ability in the logic ck so first
order logic with counting and restricted
to K variables yeah that's the first
question and the second question is yeah
everything that has to do with the
complexity of this algorithm because you
want to have the complexity of your your
complete algorithm and here in my talk
we are basically focusing on the
iteration number of the algorithm
because that's actually what's important
when you want to parallelize the
algorithm and this iteration number also
has the corresponding logics it depend
it is the quantifier depth a quantifier
rank
in seeker logic okay so I'll start with
a power yeah let's go back to the one
dimensional algorithm we have seen that
it computes a stable coloring of the of
the vertices and the stable coloring
that color refinements are the one
dimensional variant computes is the
courses or induces the courses equitable
partition of the graph which means that
it's the courses partition such that it
is regular in each class so for example
in this blue class here the blue class
he is too regular in itself because
every vertex in the blue class has
degree 2 within the blue class and
regular from both sides between every
pair of classes so here from from this
class to this class it is to regular and
from the other side it's one regular so
yeah about the the power if you have two
graphs and they have isomorphic stable
colorings with respect to some dimension
of the algorithm then this dimension
cannot distinguish them and therefore
they are called equivalent so in color
if I mean it's color if I meant
equivalent and we say that a graph is
identified by color refinement if every
equivalent graph is isomorphic to the
ground so if it suffices to apply in
graphite and color refinement
unfortunately as I said not every graph
is identified by color refinement so
here are two simple examples if you
applied the algorithm and you will
quickly see that they are equivalent
with respect to color refinement but of
course and non isomorphic so this cycle
the sixth cycle is not identified
because there's none isomorphic one
which is equivalent as to cycle length
what is may be interesting is that the
three cycle for example in the five
cycle so cycle of length 3 and of 5 they
are identified so and also it is known
that all trees identified by color
refinement already mmm
and now this leads us to the questions
which are the graphs to the question
which are the graphs that I identified
and
yeah that's cars right and a kizaemon
and me we found complete
characterisation you know in the way a
meaning that this is not only a compact
description of this grass but it also
yields a way to decide quickly whether a
given graph is identified or not so the
theorem is that it's identified if it
flips through a big cookie for us and
this has the corresponds and logics that
it's definable in the logic c2 if
they're trips to a bouquet for us I
would like to present the foofy ax but
I'm going to present another proof or
something else so I just let me just
give you the tools to understand the
theorem so I'm going to explain what a
bouquet forest is and what the flip is
so you obtain a bouquet by taking five
copies of a tree with some designated
vertex so here you have 1 2 3 4 5 trees
and they all have equivalent or yeah the
same designated vertex you bind these
trees together via a 5 cycle on these
vertices and you obtain something that
looks like a bouquet that's why we call
it like this and then from this you can
construct bouquet forests as by taking
the disjoint union of any type of vertex
color trees so everything that doesn't
contain a cycle here is a tree and you
can have isomorphic ones and non
isomorphic wants whatever you want and
then also non isomorphic vertex color
cookies so everything that you see here
is one bouquet forest and for example
these here would be isomorphic if you
didn't consider the the colors so
there's no color preserving isomorphism
so that's ok and actually this non
isomorphism is crucial in the proof so
that's why we included it in in the
definition ok so yeah and the theorem
also included some type of flipping I'm
also going to explain this you obtain
the flick of a graph by computing first
the partition that color refinement
induces so here you have it and then you
consider every pair of color classes
also a color class with itself and you
flip in it
meaning you consider the class and the
edges running within the class and the
complement so here you have the four
cycle and the complement would contain
only the diagonal and if the complement
has less edges so here it's two edges
versus four edges then you replace them
so here you only check the diagonals you
do this within every class and between
every pair of classes so here there are
two edges the complement has no edges so
you replace them and that's the flip so
the goal is to obtain a graph that has
an away few edges and why this is
allowed is because of this lemma that
graph is identified if and only if it's
flip is identified so that allowed us to
restrict ourselves and the analysis to
graphs that have few edges okay so with
some other combinatorial ingredients we
obtain this theorem and we could also
generalize it to find out relational
structures obtaining also a complete
compact characterization for them but
the thing is this characterization for
general finite finite relational
structures was only possible or nice
because the color classes in them the
vertex color classes in them are either
trivially identified or they are one of
eight peculiar looking cases so we don't
only have these eight types of
exceptions and the problem is that if
you want to generalize this to higher
dimensional variants of the algorithm
and they would not not look that nice
and they would also be infinitely many
so yeah they're strongly regular graphs
are included there and therefore you
cannot really expect to obtain a nice
characterization for them
and now I'm going to talk about the
complexity and since I'm basically going
to present results of about the
two-dimensional algorithm let's quickly
see how it works so the two dimensional
algorithm colors two tuples meaning the
arcs of the graph and in the beginning
they are colored according to whether
they an edge an on edge over loop in the
graph every arc has a color so in a
sense it is complete and then in the
refinement step they get different
colors if they had different colors
before so it's a refinement and or if
these multi-sets don't match don't focus
on them too much we're going to look at
an example and then this is applied
repeatedly until it's stable so I'm
going to explain these multi sets here
so suppose this is the graph I mean it's
not complete but these are edges in the
graph and you want to recolor or you
want to compute the new color of the
edge between the vertices one and two
then the new color contains at the
tupple and it contains as a first
component the color of the edge that it
had before so yellow and as the second
component it's this multi set and the
master set is actually computed by
looking at every third vertex in the
graph also the vertices 1 & 2 themselves
and the triangles that this vertex forms
with 1 & 2 so for example if you take
the vertex 5 then it forms a green V
with the vertices 1 & 2 so what's one of
this and then you have the same 4 6 & 9
so it's 3 times this 1 and you do this
for every other vertex on the graph and
you obtain a multiset looking like this
and that's this whole thing is the new
color so I also had an example of an a
simulation of the algorithm that I I
deleted it because I thought I wouldn't
have enough time so what you have to
remember of the algorithm is basically
that it computes colors of the arcs and
it does that based on the triangle that
this art forms in the graph with the
other vertices
the kitchen accepted yeah no it's not so
important I mean basically you just have
to have the idea of these triangles
that's yeah
okay so what's known about the
complexity is that the stable partition
of this algorithm the K dimensional
variant can be computed in time and to
the K + 1 log n where n is the size of
the graph the number of vertices but as
I said if you want to paralyze the
algorithm or want to obtain balance on
the quantifier depth of the
corresponding formulas you actually need
to look at the iteration number and
here's a table that summarizes the known
results so some of them were already
presented by crystal yesterday I'm just
going to recall them so this bound for
color refinement the one dimensional
variant was obtained by clips and
Verbitsky they actually constructed a
tricky graph on which the algorithm
needs this number of iterations to
stabilize and then for also color
refinement the trivial upper bound n
minus 1 for some n it's tight but so far
we have not really understood the
structure behind this I mean we have
found four or five ends for which it's
tight but there doesn't seem to be a
real possibility to generalize this and
then as two lower bounds it's only it's
only knowing that the lower bound is
linear and it was proven by fuga and
2001 using graphs of bounded color class
size this will be important later on and
yeah yesterday Chris have presented a
new lower bound for finite structures so
this is only about graphs and in our
understanding if you see this this new
lower bound and compared to the trim you
LuPone so that's the number of times you
can partition a set of n elements you
can refine a partition of a set of n
elements then you might suspect that
actually this is also tight but yeah
that is not the case at least not for
capers - the thing is yeah you might
want to know tight or better upper
bounds for for larger dimensions of K
but actually it was really involved
already for the case k equals two so we
restricted ourselves to this case what
we could show pascal anna is that the
number of iterations of this algorithm
on graphs of size n is at most n squared
divided by log n so yeah we have this
new log n here and you can translate
this through logics by the
correspondence that which states that in
the logic see three formulas for graphs
on n vertices require only this
quantifier depth and you do not see this
now but the way we have proven it
actually shows that if you have graphs
of foundered color class size by this
lemma and then that the upper bound is
linear so it's o of n where T is fixed
and therefore for graphs of bounders
color class size the upper bound and the
lower bound proven by Fura they match up
to a constant factor the color class
sizes are actually the so it's the
vertex color no it's no it's it's all
collector sizes but all the sizes that
appear within the algorithm I mean they
get smaller by the time but so basically
the sizes were to start at the beginning
and in the end yeah
but in the end they get smaller so
okay so how did we prove this theorem
actually we defined a game on the graph
which might seem a bit surprising but
though the game allowed us to decouple
the the dependencies between the
processes that the algorithm causes so
that we don't understand they were we
have some we have two players and one of
them has the role of what we don't
understand from the algorithm and the
other one has the role of what we can
control
so we have two players Maxie and Minnie
and they play on the graph meaning they
refine the coloring of the graph they
get and return the disk graph with a new
coloring to the other player and they do
this according to some rules which
relate the game to the Westphalian
algorithm the details are not important
to you so yeah they refine the edge
coloring of the graph they are given
they return a new colored graph to the
other play and they continue until you
get the discrete partition and all these
turns contribute to a common total cost
of the game and we could show that this
total cost forms an upper bound on the
iteration number so the player Maxie
wants to maximize the total cost and
meaning he wants to minimize them so in
order to obtain an upper bound on the
iteration number the challenge was to
prefer to provide a sufficiently good
strategy for the player mini because
it's an upper bound and then you have at
most this duration of the game
and how we did with how we found it was
we distinguished between large and small
vertex color classes in the graph and
for the large classes we use the
potential function which I'm I'm
skipping here so I am only going to have
a look at the small vertex color classes
and for this so so the idea was we
wanted to find a strategy for mini and
for this we let her construct auxiliary
graphs on which she makes some
computations and then she uses this
result to obtain or to know what moves
she should do on the original graph on
the graph that she's playing on and I'm
going to illustrate this here so here so
it's all about the small vertex color
classes you have three small vertex
color classes C 1 C 2 C 3 blue green red
and so this is the this is a part of the
graph that they plan on and if you have
that this set subset of C 2 is exactly
the neighborhood of this set in the
original graph then in the auxiliary
graph you you draw an edge you insert an
edge between a vertex corresponding to C
1 M 1 and 1 to C you to M 2 so this edge
means this relation in the original
graph and then you have if you have the
same on the other side so this is also
exactly the neighborhood of M 3 with
respect to some colors then you have
this edge so in the auxiliary graph you
have no edge colors and you also have no
direct I mean I also omitted or
directions here but the auxiliary graph
is undirected and with uncoloured edges
and then she saw so many computes this
auxiliary graph and if you have this
relation in the original graph then
actually according to the rules she's
allowed to use to make her moves
recoloring all the edges between M 1 and
M 3 is a legal move for her so I haven't
explained what her rules are but if this
is how the situation is then she
allowed to recolor these edges and you
account for this in the auxiliary graph
by inserting this edge so by completing
this triangle so there are three types
of this of these triangle completions in
the auxiliary graph and all of them
correspond to legal moves for many in
the original graph so what she does is
this is a strategy she gets a colored
back from from AXI and she goes she's
going to return another graph with a
finer edge coloring our coloring and she
does this by first cleaning up the graph
which means she accounts for some
consistency in the edge colors so yeah
this is not really important for us now
it's just a technical detail when she
has cleaned it up she computes the
auxiliary graph of the graph she has so
this one and she checks if the auxiliary
graph still allows triangle completions
so if if the triangle completions of the
auxiliary graph are not the auxiliary
graph itself so if this these edges are
missing somewhere and if this is the
case she performs one iteration of the
Vaisala liman algorithm on the graph and
accounts for these triangle completions
so one can show that if she computes one
iteration and again computes the
auxiliary graph then she has completed
all the triangles from before and she
cleans it up again and then she checks
if there are more triangle completions
now possible if there are she does this
until there are no more triangle
completions possible and this is the
graph that she returns so what we could
show is that following this strategy she
only causes extra costs all of two to
the t of n n where n is the bound on the
size of the small color classes and
actually maybe it's interesting to you
this term results from the number of
vertices the auxiliary graph has so as I
said the auxiliary graph has has as
vertices tuples of a set and a sub set
where the set is always a small vertex
color class so this is a bound on the
number of
you can have and actually from there you
get this this total bound so this is the
bound that you have for the small vertex
color classes and yeah I didn't explain
the large vertex color classes but from
them using this potential function you
get this bound so all in all you have a
total cost of this the small ones and
the big the large ones and then where T
as I said where T is the maximum size of
a small vertex color class so you have
to adjust T so that this gets optimal
and you do this you can do this by
setting it to log and divided by two and
then you get the bound I mentioned if
you just insert log and divide by two
you get this bound and ya also the bound
for the logic quantifier logical
quantifier def so this is a corollary
from the theorem but if you examine our
proof carefully you can see that we
actually didn't use counting anywhere it
seems kind of surprising also in the
case of large color classes at first it
looks like we're actually counting a lot
but in the end we only needed existence
so we can omit the counting here and we
can replace also C 3 by 3 so the logic
without counting okay
I've reached my summary so yeah I was
going to talk also about open questions
so what have we done for the
identification in dimension 1 we have
given a complete characterization that's
nice and also for for relational
structures so this I would consider this
solved but what about the identification
in higher dimensions as I said not only
without with with our method but also
because of this problem with a strongly
regular graphs you cannot really expect
to obtain a characterization in any way
a nice characterization as I said so so
this is not very promising
then as to the complexity we have found
new lower bounds for the iteration
number in dimension 2 so for the two
dimensional the Vaisala liman algorithm
so you can you can still try to improve
them but this is at least progress
yeah to the iteration number in higher
dimensions we have not yet found new
bounds but it is yeah it is possible
that you might generalize our
constructions I mean it's not
straightforward and we so far we don't
know how to do this but at least it it
might be possible and then another thing
you might want to try is to find bounds
on the iteration number to find out
relational structures actually we think
that this is possible using our
construction so you can just adapt it a
little bit and it will work for finite
relational structures but we have not
done it so far
thank you much about this initial colors
anything you so that's something you
that's the input you get a graph with
any coloring okay say I give you initial
coloring where every vertex has unique
color when you general
mr. you're done many are done here so
it's just perfect but it's probably not
interested
but you're looking at crap a summer
version in some cases some of the
vertices are obviously in small groups
so it's a restricted problem that's
interesting that's sort of small color
class and the general problem has large
color class like the whole graph yeah
well that's fine
the question is will depending on the
bottom shell color and ease
thus the sort of power of the song
changes I think so this result is from
from a year ago I think as far as I
remember the the theory is about
uncolored graphs and you can show that
if a graph is identified all vertex
colored versions of it are also
identified but only by color refinement
this is not true in higher dimensions so
so the theorem holds for uncolored
graphs you have an input which has no
colors and then the theorem holds and we
also have another theorem stating that
for color refinement if the graph is
identified then every vertex colored
version is also identified so yeah so
basically you can go back to the
uncoloured version and check it for this
one I have a question when you say okay
you can characterize
crap sir you know you can tell the
crafts are characterized with one
dimensional it's messy already yeah
which suggests to me a little bit oh you
know let's add something to the logic to
make it less messy I don't I don't know
if that that hints suitors anything this
is okay yeah I I mean usually my
perspective is not the logic specific so
but yeah maybe I mean yeah maybe there's
something else that would get rid of
your messy stuff yeah I mean also this
the case that of color refinement seems
kind of special because of this what I
just mentioned that if a graph is
identified every vertex colored version
is also identified and there is another
result which only holds about graph
which only holds about color if I mean
so yeah
this just seems a very specific nice
dimension anyway but yeah maybe yeah
it's a similar kind of question so if
you do this where you're only counting 0
& 1 so this is like characterization in
modal logic so it's known that if you
had a star operator like transitive
closure
mm-hm then you characterize every finite
structure okay so if you had something
like like that you could hope to do this
thing because this corresponds to them
like motor logic with counting okay
thank you okay okay so thank you very
much